more than 5 000 people used to live in
stepno gearsk now there are only a few
hundred left in the village
can't imagine how many explosions we
hear day and night come with me I'll
show you how we live as she leads us to
the basement the delicious smell of home
cooking is overwhelming
just another day in the shelter they say
some of these women have known each
other since kindergarten they have been
living here for months now celebrating
birthdays and giving each other courage
the front line is about five kilometers
away the village is within artillery
range the thumps can be heard even down
here
Elena is most worried at night she keeps
herself busy doing crosswords
we are here on our own sometimes when
there's no shelling we run to our
apartment but it's scary here we chat
with each other and keep ourselves
distracted
it's always astonishing to meet those
who stay in a war zone who don't want to
leave their family history behind
alone Luba had no other choice but to
join this underground Community but life
in the basement can also be lonely at
times
what can we do life needs to go on
the children and grandchildren
they are far
we don't want them to take our land we
don't want to be conquered I don't want
them to take this part
step no guess is the first Village near
the contact line in the Ukrainian
control part of zapparija the women are
concerned that the Russians might want
to take it after Moscow announced it had
annexed region
they say they will remain on the ground
hoping that day never comes
in the puritra region